en un aparente alivio de tensiones rusia
anunció que algunas de sus tropas
empezaron a dejar la frontera con
ucrania tras terminar ejercicios
militares que aseguró son de rutina
moscú tiene cerca de 130 mil soldados en
la zona no dejo claro cuántas de ellas
se irían ucrania dijo que no creerá en
el retiro hasta que lo compruebe por sí
misma posición que comparte con el
presidente de eeuu de bailén hasta ahora
no hemos verificado que las tropas rusas
estén regresando a sus bases hemos sido
transparentes con el pueblo
estadounidense y con el mundo acerca del
plan de rusia y la seriedad de esta
situación para que cualquiera pueda ver
por su cuenta qué es lo que está pasando
whatsapp por su parte el presidente ruso
vladimir putin aseguró que no quiere una
guerra pero contrastó con su postura
clara ante un posible ingreso de ucrania
a la otan hemos oído que ucrania no está
preparada para entrar en la otan hoy
conocemos esa tesis pero luego dicen que
ucrania no será aceptada mañana entonces
será aceptada cuando esté preparada
puede que entonces sea demasiado tarde
para nosotros por eso queremos resolver
esta cuestión ahora mismo
las relaciones económicas entre alemania
y rusia han sido claves para la aparente
desescalada de tensiones pero reino
unido- aseguró que hasta que no haya una
salida a gran escala de las tropas rusas
no lo tomará como un verdadero gesto y
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen pidió reforzar las
medidas coordinadas para castigar a
rusia si viola la soberanía